[Music]
today's episode is brought to you by the
new Samsung Chromebook plus the first
Chromebook made for Google Play what's
going on guys
spider-man homecoming is swinging into
theaters and since Marvel keeps
expanding its roster of characters we
decided to take a look back at some of
your favorite heroes and villains in
let's start off with Spidey himself Tom
Holland before he started web-swinging
and hanging with Tony Stark he was
running from a not so friendly
neighborhood tsunami in 2012 the
impossible check it out plus something
else
travelling to you oh god I got way too
little brothers damn first the tsunami
then we all know what happened to
spider-man's Uncle Ben Tom Holland is
cursed
I mentioned Tony Stark earlier because
of course Iron Man have to pop up in a
Marvel movie here's Robert Downey jr. in
one of his very first roles as some kind
of weird 80s
slash 50s greaser and a movie called
first born thank you God the closing in
on us
what do you want chocolate chicken yeah
Jesse wants us and they can do a trick
yeah firstborn was also the film debut
of Corey Haim and co-starred Sarah
Jessica Parker and Robocop himself Peter
Weller Michael Keaton was Batman he was
Birdman and now he's vulture but in the
1970s he was part of an ensemble on Mary
Tyler Moore's short live variety show
alongside David Letterman my name is
Michael Keaton and quite frankly I you
know like I understand it I mean I mean
I know why my name is Michael Keaton but
I don't understand why I keep getting
letters from all these guys testing for
dating tips you know but hey I get them
I'm glad Michael Keaton got a lot more
chances to shine after that because I'm
going to be honest that was bad man
Marissa Tomei plays Aunt May in the
latest spider-man movie and saying that
sentence makes me feel really old
here's her very first movie role as
screaming girl in the can
classic the toxic avenger how'd she
memorize all her lines
Donald lovers big break as a writer was
on NBC's 30 rock but did you know that
he also appeared on the show as an actor
here's a quick cameo from Donald aka
childish gambino I have one thing to say
to only you be yourself and I'm talking
to you clearly gay kid who told he just
made me laugh or with two words than the
last two Adam Sandler movies I watched
combined one of the newest additions to
the MCU is Captain Marvel played by
Oscar winner brie Larson before she was
in the superhero game brie Larson was an
aspiring pop star here she is performing
her single hope has wings from the
cinematic classic barbie and the magic
of pegasus
[Music]
real arson has already got to Oh in her
he got that's Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony and
if she played her cards right I bet that
song that her got her that sweet sweet
Grammy also joining the MCU is Michael B
Jordan and next year's highly
anticipated black panther but here he is
in his acting debut on an HBO show no
not the wire his debut was on The
Sopranos hey what are you doing wait
he's big mean ain't doing nothing yet
you did you through that rap one a fool
pick up leave me alone comeback kid you
pick it up it's great to watch Michael B
Jordans evolution on HBO from The
Sopranos to the wire to that five
minutes of Fantastic Four that I
accidentally recorded after a deep last
weekend Black Widow herself Scarlett
Johansson has quite the IMDB but scroll
down our IMDB page you'll find home
alone three I'll explain the toilet seat
down on his thing again Oh
luckily for ScarJo home alone four came
along in 2002 and saved her from
appearing and what most people consider
the worst home alone now it's only the
second worst home alone Clark Gregg has
been holding down the MCU fort on TV as
Agent Coulson on agents of shield but
did you know he's a hardcore baller
check him out in 2004 in good company
which incidentally also starred Scarlett
Johansson
Oh No do it baby baby as Captain America
Chris Evans plays the world's most
patriotic hero but he also knows how to
drop some science here he is in his
acting debut an educational video called
biodiversity wild about life I thought
you liked taking me fishing fishing
here's a waste water so polluted that if
you ever caught anything we have to
throw it back
look look about the trash
people don't care of course we can't
talk about cap without mentioning us BFF
and platonic life mate Bucky Barnes the
Winter Soldier
here's Sebastian Stan still fighting the
good fight against the commies in Hot
Tub Time Machine brewskis and these are
their secret calming weapon what are you
talking look at this stuff man huh it
could be spies or something I don't know
but I mean it seemed a little young to
be spies you know come on Chaz there
could be some kind of 21 Jump Street
spy battalion type dudes fun fact the
Russo brothers were originally going to
resurrect Bucky using a hot tub time
machine to send cap back to the past
it's totally true don't look it up
though when gwyneth paltrow isn't giving
bujji lifestyle advice on our website
goop she can sometimes be found playing
Pepper Potts but do you remember her
role in 1991's hook
why are you crying watching me Wendy
Moira Angela darling
what you you know hanging out with Peter
Pan and immature guy who can fly was
probably good training for dating Tony
Stark slash Iron Man an immature
billionaire who can fly bangarang Tom
Hiddleston plays Loki Thor's eccentric
and often evil brother
but here he is being seduced in a park
in the British sitcom suburban shootout
oh really so I told you concentrate are
you okay my airway says who any tight
and there doesn't hold on to the bed I
mean even microRNA you could just carry
me that could be very clean
the woman seducing Tom Hiddleston was
actress Ruth Wilson better known for her
role on Luther with Aegis Elba who plays
Heimdall in the Thor movies also
starring Tom Hiddleston I wonder what
Kevin Bacon fits into that six degrees
finally like an early MCU post-credit
scene we've saved samuel l.jackson znik
fury for last here's one of his early
roles in 1988 classic comedy coming to
America fonio all of it don't stall me
back let go anybody move out blow you up
and hit off 30 years later Samuel
Jackson looks and sounds exactly the
same
there's only one logical conclusion is a
cyborg from the future become super okay
with weirdly well I was a good time
were there any deep cuts that we missed
or did any totally surprise you
let us know in the comments section
below we want to hear it come see us
live in San Diego at screen junkie
central featuring us and surprise
celebrity guests July 22nd at the House
of Blues learn more and get tickets at
screen junkies calm slash tickets but
wait before you come and angrily about
not being able to get there don't
hurry if you aren't in San Diego and
don't have a hotel during the convention
we got your back go to screen junkies
calm / SJ central because we are
bringing one lucky fan and a friend down
to San Diego to experience everything
the screen junkies way to enter you must
be 21 or over and the u.s. resident
thanks to the new Samsung Chromebook
plus the first Chromebook made for
Google Play for helping to make this
possible
click the boxes to watch more videos
I've been Hal Rudnick you've been the
viewers thanks for watching
hit me up on Twitter bye bye
[Music]